before you know you fell in love with
klay thompson's shot the steph curry
shot chris mullen shot the shot that was
known in the bay area was purpose short
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so demar derozan known as the mid-range
killer right now his mid-range game so
potent and so powerful 15-footer
18-footer post-play
coming off screen catch you
most nba players aren't used to guarding
mid-range because everybody plays and
they defend the three-point line demar
derozan has made a good career in the
mid-range he reminds me of another
player back in the day
and most of you nba players currently
know him now because he works with the
nba players association but before he
was working with the nba players
association he was working on us
purvis short puts it down the short
knocks it down from outside short beats
the clock scores purvis short
got it
what a fight he's right
pervy short was giving it to us i mean
coming off screens
knocking it down he had a high
high
high arching shot that's what he was
known for his pretty high auction shot
in his high whites
wore them high white socks number 45
purvi short before you know you fell in
love with klay thompson's shot steph
curry shot chris mullen shot the shot
that was known
in the bay area
was purple short
herb is short there's that good soft
touch with a man from jackson state
slicing and swimming
nifty little move and eight foot hook
shot nice running hook by purvis short
they're shooting lights out so far what
made purpose so deadly in the mid-range
was his setup you know it's all about
you know his footwork he would come off
screens and his catch and shoot was
always started fundamentally down low so
his down low setup was so perfect and so
flawless no matter how fast he was
moving no matter how hard he was
dribbling his setup fundamentally was
always so tight that when he rose up to
shoot the basketball he always had
perfect form perfect arch on the shot
and his arch again was higher than
others i guess he wanted to let you know
if you watch it long enough it's going
to feel good to you
[Laughter]
the 17-footer again good purpose short
getting to his spot and getting the roll
home this is purvis short nice release
it's bailey off his feet two more
purvis averages like 25 26 points a
night in the nba always a top five score
in the nba when he was playing and he
was scoring the basketball and he always
did it in a very silent way very similar
to derozan you look up before you know
it derozan's got 24 points and you go
where when did that happen that's how
perfect short was so pervic short demar
derozan mid-range killers
[Applause]